Et cet hiver qui commence, on ne
sait p
Jean-Sloutier.
♪ ♪ ♪bre, un aubre, un aubre, ue
hiver à survivre au froid.
8, 3149 itinérants avaient
été dénombrés dans la ville.
La pandémie en a jeté la rue.
FIONA CROSSLING, directrice
générale, Accueil Bonneau
- On estime une lement, delemen%
dans le nombre de personnes qui
viennent à l'Accueil Bonneau qui
sont des nouvelles personnes.
- Le c
Bonneau, qui est ouvert depuis
s, n'a jamais accueilli
autant d'itinérants.
Ils viennent ici pour mang
quelques vêtements.
- Les gens qui tombent
nouvellement en situation
d'itinérance, bien, c'est sûr
peut-être, pendant la pandémie.
Ils ont perdu leur logemen
parce que les loyers coûtent
juste trop chers.
un endroit comme ici?
t quasiment quasiment quasimentu
pour moi tous les jours.
dans la salle de repos, n'a plus
t depuis février 2020.
FRANÇOIS DEJEAN, itinérant
- Je trouve que ça fait beaucoup
promène dans
la rue, là. À un moment donné,
quelconque parce que
ça n'a plus d'allure, monsieur.
- Comme les sans-abris sont plus
sanitaires empêchent les refuges
de nuité, plusieurs sont
contraints de dormir au centre
de jour de l'Accueil Bonneau,
ce qu'on ne voyait pas avant.
des nuits à me promener, et puis
de pas
2-3 jours sans dormir. Puis,
je viens ici, ils me laissent
- Quelques unités de
débordements ouvertes 24 heures
Celle  180
places. Sam Watts, de la Mission
Bon Accueil, l'a mise sur pied.
augmentation de l'itinérance
depuis
SAM WATTS, président-directeur
général, Mission Bon Accueil
mais ce qu'on voit,
tre une hausse
de 600 personnes.
rencontre sont reconnaissants de
pouvoiôtel-Dieu.
ROBERT ROCHELEAU, itinérant
- La nourriture, on se douche,
seul espoir pour l'instant.
CHANTALE MERCIER, itinérante
- Des fois, on avait pas
à terre, on dormait partout.
Puis, c'était vraiment affreux.
Puis moi, je ne
- "Je frissonne actuellement,
nous dit Charles,
alors imaginez si je devais
dormir
iver dernier,
un Innu de la Côte-Nord, Raphaël
André, a été retrouvé mort gelé
dans une toilette chimique parce
que lefermé en rfermé en rfermén
d'une éclosion.  Peu après,
cette halte-chaleur, qui porte
son nom, a été ouverte
Alexandra Ambroise en est la
coordonnatrice. Lors de notre
visite, elle et son équipe
une autre nuit : une quinzaine
de matelas pour dormir
et de la nourriture,
qui sera servie jusqu'au matin.,
notamment chez les Autochtones.
ALEXANDRA AMBROI
- Ils arrivent à Montréalpour d,
la cour, puis après ça,
ils sont comme p
Au mois de février environ,on pn
20-25-30 personnes.
Là 400 et 500
personnes par soir.
- Malgion, obtenir
un financement reste compliqué.
Pour l'instant, la halte-chaleur
a un budget pour fonctionner
jusqu'merais ça que la tente
soit... je dis pas qu'elle soit
là pour toujours, mais qu'elle
soit là jusqu'à temps qu'on
stable, sécuritaire aussi.
- Et des haltes-
par exemple, sont importantes,
font partie de l'écosystème.
c'est une solution ou est-ce que
c'est un "plaste
- La vraie solution, répète-t-on
dans lplusplusplusplusplusplusps
de logements sociaux.
- Donc, chaque année, on part
mesures d'urgence hivernales.
Ça tat... ça coûte
une fortune. C'est : où est-ce
que je vais manger aujourd'hui?
cette nui cette nui cette nui ?
Mais ça, ça ne règle rien.
- En attendant, plus
de 1400 lits sont disponibles
plus que jamais.
JOSEFINA BLANCO, responsab
de l'itinérance Ville de Mtl
- On est bien conscient qu'ilétr
péreniser les re
- À moyen terme, la nouvelle
responsable du dossierespère pla
et de Québec. Et
sur quatre ans.
- On a promis 1200 unités
d'itinérance, dont une partie
pour l
ainsi qu'on a promisde doude doe
à l'itinérance, qui va passer
de tros par annés par annés par.
- Plus d'argent pour veniren ai.
- C'est difficile, c'est...
ses qu'il faut
encadrer. Il y a la tête,
il y a le psychologique,
ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.u!
Des HLM, puis que le monde neso.
C'est épouvantable, ça a jamais
été de
- Ce s
signer un bail dans le nord
de la ville.- Je m- Je m- Je m-.
Dieu merci! Merc
Dieu, merci!
Bien, bonne chance, vous
♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪